it's it's still nice outside so I mean I
have no objection if you want to leave
now um but um also I'm really excited
this is the first time I'm using
a so you can go fast you can go
slow okay even um okay so uh it's about
expansion and there will be an sdp in
this stock uh and uh some other things
it's joint work with Anan Lewis who's
now at Princeton and Prasad who's here
okay graph expansion just to get my
notation down a graph with weights on
the edges non negative uh for any subset
you look at the total weight of edges
leaving the subset divide by the total
weight of edges in the subset or its
complement incident to the subset was
complement and that ratio is the
expansion uh of the subset and then the
minimum overall subsets of the vertices
of the graph is graph expansion Edge
expansion and we had to compute
exactly inm square root log constant
square root log
approximation which improves the earlier
login approximation ofon ra
and okay great problem uh now this other
view the spectral view of adjy
matrices uh you could have General
weights uh normalized so that every row
sums to one plus normalized again so
it's just identity minus this
normalized uh adjacency
Matrix convenient you know the the the
the smallest uh I value is zero and the
second one is uh is this quadratic
form uh which you can interpret as uh
the minimum overall
vectors um orthogonal to the degree
sequence of uh the sum overall edges of
the weight times the difference squared
divided by the sum overall vertices weed
by the degree okay it's clearly non
negative so sum of
squares um
okay um Peron forus say Lambda 2 is zero
if and only if the graph is uh
disconnected seen this times and if it's
close to zero then is it close to
disconnected so chiger answered
thiser Alman saying that in fact it's uh
um at most Square < tk2 Lambda 2 why
let's see one One Direction so there are
two inequalities here this is the
definition of Lambda 2 no change and now
we relax I mean I added this term which
is zero because uh uh X is orthogonal to
D um and now let's uh restrict to only
01 vectors so which specify subsets it
can only go
up uh now if you interpret what it means
the subset so X is the indicator Vector
of some subset you end up with the
weight of the subset and the weight of
its complement and that's at most uh
twice
5G okay because one of them is half the
weight of the
graph okay now jer's
algorithm for the other inequality take
the igen vector for Lambda 2 sort it
according to its
value cordinates and then take subsets
that are consistent with the Sorting so
prefixes of
this of those take the one that has the
smallest ratio smallest
expansion and this gives you OT Lambda 2
and really the only inequality used in
the proof is scy
shortz
um there are now very nice alternative
ways to interpret it you can for example
say pick a random number R between 0 and
1 and then you
see uh whether uh you take as your
subset all the I for which x i squ is
less than
R and uh that also gives you s bound
okay so I I want do the the K schwarts
proof here um one nice thing here is
that it gives a method to certify
constant Edge expansion so if the
expansion is Alpha you get a certificate
that it's at least Alpha squar
okay
um
okay it's very useful in applications
and in thetical
work um maybe it's uh not something
something that you'd find in a chapter
in a graph Theory Book but I think the
next graph Theory Book will have it as a
feature okay so here's what I want to do
in this talk first vertex expansion
which is instead of counting we'll
Define in a minute formally instead of
counting edges leaving the subset you
want to count vertices how many vertices
are are near a near a subset and what
can we how can we approximate it and can
we certify constant vertex
expansion then hyper graphs right so not
just pairs but subsets are edges what
can we do there what does what is
expansion and are there such
inequalities and then whatever bounds we
we know and we can get here how much how
far are they from the best possible so
that's
the okay so vertex expansion is uh you
can Define in a few different ways I'll
use the symmetric version so for a
subset you're counting the number of
vertices in the subset that have a a
neighbor outside and outside the subset
that have a neighbor inside sometimes
you do the outer only sometimes you do
the inner only we do both these are all
equivalent up to constant factors for
approximation purposes in Pol
time okay so that's good now I've
removed the weights for Simplicity you
can do all this with non- negative
weight
so and we'll also assume that it's a
regular graph for this part of the talk
so again that Rel that makes more
notation but it doesn't change any of
the ideas here the minimum vertex
expansion is the expansion of a subset
for which this ratio is
minimized that's the EXP vertex
expansion of the graph this is also a
fundamental parameter and lots of
applications uh and also has a square
root log and
approximation uh with
the different uh method uses at least
the one that first gave the square root
log was a different method now if you
use the second igen Vector so if you use
the Fielder Vector then you get
something that grows as square root of
the the degree * Lambda
2 okay and this is already in Al's
paper
um so you know if the degree is constant
then these things are within constant
factors The Edge expansion and the
vertex expansion anyway and of course
the bounds also but what if the degre is
a parameter that's growing independent
of whatever approximation you want so
here is a
question um I have an graph it's a
Vertex expander of expansion let's say
0.1 can you certify that its expansion
is at least
01 okay so I want the polinomial size
proof that its expansion is at least 0
you can do this for a
expansion so what should we do uh sorry
I went we think should you think of the
degree the interesting degree as being
what log n/ to SC like what's the it's
just something growing independent of
Lambda okay so uh uh you'll see what the
bounds are in a minute for for now it's
a separate parameter D so it's just
independent of Lambda and n
and
yeah uh we'll give a bound based on the
degree that works for any degree but
yeah
okay okay so here is a way to formulate
this is an equality the same thing but
I'm writing it as a an integer program
or an
integer uh uh
ratio denominator is the same as you
have in the edge expansion case it's
just counting a subset basically if x is
the indicator Vector of a subset this is
essentially counting the size of the
subset times its complement but the
numerator what we're doing is that for
every
Edge for every
vertex you uh see is there an edge
Crossing or not right so for every I you
look over all J and check is there at
least one Edge going across and if there
is one at least one of these terms will
be one and you only count the max so you
count once for every vertex that has
something outside something on the other
side okay so this is a symmetric vertex
expansion right it's going to count for
every vertex one if it has a neighbor on
the other side okay so that's exact and
I I just wrote the same thing and so
it's not the Min you get the product
divided by n in this formulation as
usual but that's just a factor of two of
so so this this of chus inequality no
problem uh at least with this definition
of course uh the question is uh whether
we can compute it as it is I mean these
are all subsets so no not efficiently so
let's relax it just like you get doing
in Edge expansion you relax to get
a solvable polom Time solvable
program H
now when you relax it same relaxation
but just going to Real vectors instead
of 0 1 and since I assume constant
degree it's orthogonal to
one uh since is orthogonal to one I can
drop the the the the subtraction term
and here here is the
formulation and bobov udali who defined
this parameter as it is
here
uh proved that
um this parameter in fact uh is has is
can be thought of as giving a sugar
inequality
uh this one I basically it's from the
definition we just saw it this takes
some work we'll see in a minute so it's
not it's not square < tk2 but there's
some constant
here
okay they didn't okay so that then
raises the question can you compute this
right do is this an effective
approximation
um okay so I think everybody in the
audience knows what to do next right
let's say together
1 2 3 SVP come on guys one two 3
S was I tried sorry okay so here it's
already written there okay um I thought
it was hard but I
guess anyway here is the the the the
thing here you can still leave I'm
sorry here it is so we okay so you just
symbolically replace the XI with vectors
instead of uh real numbers and uh the
squares with squared
Norms that's okay and it's forget about
the orthogonality constraint we'll put
back the the subtraction term and since
we relaxed from real numbers to vectors
we get a something that can only be
smaller it's very minimizing can only be
smaller so it's smaller than this Lambda
infinity and you can compute it right
right it's uh it's just an
sdp um using only inner
products
okay so yeah what about the ma it's just
a linear constraint right so you uh you
you this is a this is a linear term in
the in the so
sorry so so let me just take one more
step so what are the variables the
variables are the inner products X I do
XJ so this is a linear function here
it's all linear here so for each vertex
I let's put a variable that is uh at
least uh the distance for all Alpha I
such that Alpha I is larger Alpha is
larger than what you get for each vertex
for the vertex right so this you turn
into a linear constraint you have a
linear objective function and uh this is
also another constraint and you minimiz
this
I was going to say like uh use uh one of
these soft Max functions why don't you
do that
instead for the Max uh oh I see so like
do a summation but you don't have to
like heed the blah blah blah right right
right yeah
so you know how they do this
and these guys you know multiplicate way
sort of you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah yeah yeah sort of
know any yeah yeah yeah just like why
Max why hard Max why not to a some kind
of exponentiated combination of these
all these kids are using these
days which
ones find them
out okay so uh um okay I don't know you
can this is already convex okay right I
mean this is already convex so why not
so I don't need to do anything further
this is already an exactly Sol I mean up
to arbitary accuracy solvable thing
um okay and and now here's the theem
um
um you know you have Lambda this this we
already showed by definition now this is
a relaxation so uh uh what I need to
show is so this sdp is also a lower Bond
it's fitting over here sorry I should
have written one more line sdp smaller
than this now this will recover a cut
which is at most square root of the STP
solution Times log D not the D that you
get from Cher but log d Edge expansion
log D and of course since sdp is lower
than Lambda Infinity it's root Lambda
infity so the approximation is order
root log
D
okay now so what's the algorithm it's a
you solve the sdp okay you have these
vectors pick one random gussian
vector and uh you know this could have
been discovered before Max cut of the
same complexity pick one gusin vector
project onto this G Vector your vectors
so you get uh a sorting of the vertices
consider Cuts in that order basically
the Cher sweep go use prefixes in that
order take the best one with respect to
vertex
expansion or or the modern view take a
random threshold cut that's it right
that's the
algorithm so you solve the STP you have
n vectors you project onto a line and
then you consider all the end
GS okay so why really all I to show you
is that after projection your value
didn't go up much because after that I
can just use bobali who said that given
a vector goes up by you know what you
recover is square root of that times the
constant okay um so they don't State
their algorithm like this but in fact
it's it's it's embedded in there so okay
so so all you need to see is this
inequality right and what is this saying
um you know it's two things that are
concentrated near their expectations
this one just doesn't even have any Max
or anything it's just a summation the Yi
are what uh gaussian * XI so it's just
itself the length squ of a gaussian it's
concentrated near its expectation what
about the numerator well each of these
terms is just concentrated near its
expectation but there's a Max but a Max
of how many things only D things so you
will lose uh square root log D and in
the Square you lose log D sum it up
that's just a sum so you lose nothing
and that's
l this is really where the L comes
yeah that's it this is the the rest is
constant I mean you lose the square root
but
that okay so let's
so so
then could you improve it with all these
kind of things that James is doing like
Gan processes and these kind of things
that would be very nice so I I try to
give you a partial answer um but before
we do that you know it seems simple
enough let's generalize it okay let's
why not so hypergraph expansion well the
motivation is that you want a common
generalization we have the same
algorithm for both almost you have a
vector and you do a sweep why not find a
common generalization of two problems
they look like two different problems so
here is hypergraph expansion and what is
hypergraph expansion you have edges
which are now subsets instead of pairs
and uh the expansion is uh um you have a
subset of vertices and you count how
many subsets you know how many Hypes
have at least one vertex inside and one
vertex
outside okay so that's the hypergraph
problem you have a hyper graph you have
a subset of vertices and for each hyper
Edge you count all the ones if they're
weighted Count Their weights which cross
this bound which means we have an
intersection with both
sides
okay uh so that's the
definition and you can see that this
captures both Edge and vertex expansion
in the edge case it's just trivially the
hyper edges are the edges so edges cross
in the vertex case you define the hyper
Edge as the set of all neighbors of each
vertex those are the hyperedges yes
doesn't that create a problem about as
in two neighbors as in that would
qualify as a cut here that's not
necessarily true ver sorry when you I
have to define the Hypes for vertex
expansion I have to define a graph for
which we'll apply this I just said it's
a neighborhood right sorry yes for each
vertex it's the neighborhood
right that's the hyper AG so you will
count it
once you you count it once if if it
crosses no but so so here's so yeah two
factor of two so you might count from
both sides no no no but in the whole
neighborhood if just if just two two
neighbors are are on the other opposite
sides of the cut then you'll count it
for if it gets counted for every vortex
in that neighborhood but you're you're
you're you're creating only one hyper
for this uh
vertex so here is the the the formul of
the max formulation for each hyper Edge
you are again looking at whether there
is at least one element of the hyperedge
now this e represents the hyperedge
instead of an edge right it's a set of
points so checking for each hyper Edge
whether it crosses this value is one
only if it crosses it's the same
formulation as before over a different
set of
subset Ed expansion both both exactly
Edge expansion but it captures Vex
expansion on the yeah exactly exactly
and then now why not Define uh parameter
which is an sdp the same s DP except the
set of constraints instead of being uh
uh one for each vertex now it's one for
each hyperedge and you get this using
the same uh same method as bobali for
the steter and in fact you can
approximate this to within log R where R
is the maximum size of a
hyperedge because you have to take the
max over our
gum sorry there there we sum over
vertices yes here a hyper these are
hyper edges a hyperedge corresponds to a
single
vertex I'm defining one hyper Edge for
the neighborhood of each vertex of your
original
graph and just okay and so you get this
to within log r i mean this is almost a
symbolic uh change to
the now an Lewis and Yuri I should makf
have shown recently that with this
formulation they get a square root log
approximation if you also add the L2 squ
metric constraints so you take this sdp
add the L2 Square metric constraints you
get square root log which means that you
have one algorithm now and the rounding
algorithm is arv you have one algorithm
now for expansion Vex expansion you
don't need you know the spreading
constraints and so on which you
previously used
for something useful is
coming now I want to say a few more
things about this because uh it seems
interesting so this is the basic
continuous
parameter you know one nice thing about
Edge expansion is that
the the the parameter is corresponds
very closely to this random process a
random walk according to the weights of
graph and uh so for either you can keep
in mind vertex expansion if you prefer
or hyper graphic expansion is there a
random process that matches this
parameter uh the simple random walk the
rate at which it converges is exactly
Lambda 2 for I mean Lambda 2 of the what
about this is there some process and so
here is the process uh start with some
Distribution on the vertices okay so at
any point you have distribution of
vertices that's the current distribution
and we're going to make a change on it a
local change normally what do you do you
uh look at uh you you basically average
over the neighbors that's the normal
random walk you pick you go to each
neighbor with probability proportional
to to to to the edge here you pick a
random
hyperedge you look at the largest
difference the pair of vertices the pair
of vertices that have the largest
difference so if you go stick to vertic
expansion you pick a pick up you you you
pick the neighborhood of vertex
including the vertex and you you see
which neighbor has the largest
difference with it
and you make a little transfer of mass
between those two only 1/ 2D * the
difference between the two so so
whichever are the the where you see the
maximum discrepancy we transfer some
Mass that's that's the process what is d
d is the degree so I'm assuming constant
degree right now but it would be the the
hyper it's a dular hyper dular hyper so
D is R for the Hy hypog
sorry of not the number of the size of
the hyp the size of the hypi D uniform D
uniform hyper d r sorry this should be R
since I moved here
to okay so if you think of this as a
process you know this step of updating X
it's some process that's updating a
vector x wait actually sorry so the
previous operator you defined when
you're incrementing by X i- XJ divided
by that is that the I'm a little
confused with the D's and rs is that the
size of the hyper Edge or is it the
regularity size of the hyper Edge the
size of the hyper Edge we don't need the
regularity of the hyper graph we just
need the size of the hyper Edge R there
for the set yes for the ver expansion R
is D but yeah okay y yeah H so so there
is a vector X the current XT we apply
this operator which you know picks
randomly each hyper Edge and then uh uh
it makes this transfer mass and that
gets us an X Vector so are you do it
actually parall for all the other edges
just like you think of as random walk
right you can you it's you're updating
the probability distribution each
vertex um picks uh decides what you know
with the current probability it decides
where to
go exactly so it's like you know in in
the in the in the in the normal random
work it's just a linear operator you
take the transition Matrix and apply to
the current V yeah it's not linear it's
something but it gives you an exact rule
how to do it okay so does this converge
to what and at what
rate and uh Le proved that under some
mild conditions you know these are
basically what you require even in the
edge expansion case like it has should
not be bipartite and it should not it
should be connected and so on the
process will convert at the range one at
the rate 1/ gamma 2 this is this
continuous parameter we defined and to a
vector which is stable under this
operator of course that's what
convergence means that when you apply
this operator again it doesn't change
okay but uh um this is gamma 2 just to
remind you we can rewrite gamma 2 like
this because this is now an operator
that's capturing the Max and all that so
so so just second g 2 is this thing that
we don't know how to compute right yes
we don't know how to compute ex we don't
know how to run the process we know how
to run the
process GMA 2 is telling you the rate at
which the process
converges well I mean uh not efficiently
necessarily right what if gamma 2 is
very small can it be exponentially
small I think so I mean U but I guess
the reason you don't know it is that you
you have to start
wait a minute sorry yeah when it
converges at that rate that means it's
that's like the worst possible
conversion rate right right we don't
know the worst we we right that's the
point so you can't you just pick a
random X and try and measure the rate of
convergence that might not wait a Mee
for normal uh random walk the rate of
convergence actually is Lambda 2 yeah
doesn't matter where you
start do if you start from the worst
possible
condition yeah h i mean this has to be
the point right because otherwise you
could compute it yes yes so this is a
bound on rate at rate at most one over
gam
yeah well it's still not clear to me
that otherwise you can compute it
because you have to actually measure the
changes it actually does give you like
if you run the process maybe some sense
it does give you some kind of relaxation
some kind of I'm getting confused lower
bound or upper bound some kind of bound
on
G which might may or may be worse or
better than the sdp some some kind of
approximation yeah so um okay this the
process
that and um I'm really putting this up
because uh you know you could Define a
thousand different
processes and this is one that matches
the particular parameter we defined
because of the max in there but uh I
don't know which ones are interesting
which ones are computable okay I don't
know what else to do with this
um so say that Computing it is the most
interesting question right now but uh
it's
certainly okay wait so if you if you
find the x that minimizes uh this uh
would it give you
a square root without the log constant
square root yes that's that's that that
yes exactly
yeah I mean whatever X you have you can
look at its value as if it's a rally
coent and you get square root
of um okay so question is can you do
better than this log d square root log D
so on and more precisely can we
approximate in polinomial time Edge
expansion to better than square root of
right which is what Cher gives you
vertex expansion to better than square
root of log D and uh within this maybe
an very important special Cas is can you
certify vertex expansion is at least
some constant in polinomial time and
then hypergraphic expansion to better
than square root of log so these are the
bounds other than this is what we can
get right now up to constants and can
you do
better I mean this question motivated a
lot of developments over the past
uh so uh and this has an interesting
extra parameter maybe it's easier to
prove right something because problem is
harder maybe uh okay so let me remind
you of uh the first talk from the second
day which uh the second do from the
first
we can play a game
actually sounds other than the speaker
knows let me remind you of minute 17 and
like
slide for those of you who are not
here okay so here's a
problem um given a graph you know
another expansion problem not just okay
you have to distinguish between two
cases so it's a prob of
deciding one or the
other uh does there exist a subset of
measure you can make this at most no at
most a Delta fraction of the vertex
weight so that its Edge expansion is at
most Epsilon Epsilon is part of the
input uh or is it the case for every
subset of small measure the expansion is
at least 1 minus Epsilon so those are
the two things you have to distinguish
and these guys uh conjectured that uh
this is NP
heart I think it's ridiculous myself but
they ConEd it's NP heart
okay but ridiculous things are fun to
work on right I mean it's great
yeah so so so okay the polom Alm and be
done I know I know I know yeah let him
get to the end of the
talk did they Conor it's empty hard just
that it's hard would I mean it's the no
no no no the the conjecture isent hard
yeah I mean there are precise parameter
values for which uh but yes just like
unique games and it turns out that this
is I shouldn't say this is a this is an
easier problem than unique games in the
sense that if you can solve this problem
uh you can solve a unique games
instance get that wrong okay so
it's uh it's easier than unique games am
I right yes yes
okay I was I was reading an article the
article because sashka got the neevo
word yeah he he he only says well it's
probably in between right he may be in
between so he's not sticking to NP
hardest let's see to Sashi actually
still thinks it's NP okay still tries to
prove it
so so you know yeah this would be even
harder to prove NP hard but it's there
okay okay so
um I don't know I mean you just want to
distinguish expansion by a huge Factor
that's okay so here are the theorems
assuming let's assume this now it's very
we don't know right now there's no polom
time algorithm for it uh uh there is an
algorithm that does it in subx
exponential time AR barer for this
problem here so it's not 2 to the end
it's 2 to the end to the
Epsilon small Epsilon but
uh sorry same
yeah uh I guess order whatever but uh
but there's nothing close to PO so what
uh quickly followed their conjecture the
r conure is this paper by ragra tulsani
which showed that assuming this
hypothesis Edge expansion is in fact
hard to approximate to better than what
Shar gives
you up
to Shar give you square root up you
can't do better than that if this is
actually hard so basically you know you
need to solve this problem if you want
to do better than square
root is a great way to focus right so um
you know for expansion We have basically
no lower right I mean we cannot prove
1.01 hardness we cannot prove
uh
hard for end to the log n
okay
um what we managed to do is that uh for
vertex expansion in fact it's square
root of log this is the upper bound I
just showed you so if you want to
improve better than this you better uh
do better on
small and as a result in fact it's hard
to decide if a Vertex has you know so
this is just saying if a graph has
vertex expansion less than Epsilon or at
least square root of epon log D so you
cannot actually certify constant
expansion of constant vertex expansion
unless s is false so it mean your
parameter gamma 2 it start approximate
within log d h square root uh gamma 2
within log D yes better than better than
better than log D
yes okay so how does this work you know
um this is sort of a path that has been
laid out over the past decade for
several problems and uh uh I will uh
sort of um sketch some of them and show
you some of the new parts of this in the
remaining uh 10 minutes so you start
with an instance right where you want to
solve uh this expansion problem we're
going to show that uh look if you can do
vertex expansion to better than if you
can distinguish vertex expansion Epsilon
from square root EPS log D then you can
solve the S
problem okay that's the ultimate
conclusion so so on the way uh some nice
things happen uh this step I've
basically skipped for this talk
completely we assume we are already
interested only in symmetric vertex
expansion you lose a constant
here
um balanced vertex expansion is the same
as vertex expansion but you're only
looking at vertex expansion of uh
subsets of measure at least constant
fraction okay so not the vertex
expansion of the entire craft but only
subsets of this could make it harder or
easier but okay but in fact if you can
do this you can do the general case and
so these are these two steps are
basically graph theoretic
reductions now we in this Pap we Define
a intermediate problem which is called
balanced analytic expansion I'll Define
it in a minute and that will be the link
between uh small set expansion and uh
and vertex
expansion okay so what is this balanced
analytic
expansion
so uh you have a set of vertices V which
could be an infinite set and uh you have
a probability distribution over d+1
subsets subsets of size d+1 okay so
there is some distribution specified
over subsets of size d plus1 so if it's
an explicit hyper graph maybe these are
D plus1 uniform hyper graph and just say
uniform on the Hypes but but it could be
something for and uh this will also have
a
marginal on
pairs okay so if you have a on subsets
you look at what what it induces on
pairs okay and so what is this quantity
this balanced analytic
expansion um first we Define analytic
expansion we look at the expectation
over this uh distribution over
subsets um for 01 functions so these are
specifying some subset of
vertices uh this fun this is a familiar
term here right it's looking U at the
difference between Yi and X the function
value are you different is the function
different but you only looking at uh a
tuple that was picked from this
distribution so it's a distribution on
d+1 tuples you pick a tuple the first
one is is is special the first one in
the Tuple and you look to see whether
the difference in the function between
the first and any of the rest is large
whatever is the largest that's what you
count uh denominator you're doing the
same thing but you're just looking at
pairs from the marginal distribution so
denominator simply counts the size of
the set times the size of its complement
that's all the denominator counts so the
one is a distribution over single
vertices and X and Y are independently
no no P1 is the distribution over pairs
induced by by by by this distribution
ofes and what does it what do you mean
by IND that you pick a and
El so we can think of the distribution
so we can think of the distribution
already as a hyper hyper graph
so so so this looks kind of directly
like hypergraph what you define as
hypergraph expansion right yeah almost
yes yes it looks very much like that
it's it looks very weighted the hyper
and I made it a bit more General by
saying it's a distribution on tles and
so on distribution of tles is a weed
hyp exactly yeah fine that's a discrete
version but we'll in fact pass to a
continuous version but that's okay okay
for d one P1 would just be equal to
P yes yes that's right so for D equal to
1 you get expansions no no very good for
let's take D equal to 1 is a good case D
equal to 1 uh you you you you get uh
pairs right so you're counting if it's
different over the edges of the
graph oh you're right sorry extremely
thank you so P1 is on the P1 is the
margin on vertices so you take two
independent it's like you're weighing
vertic you ver is just a marinal you
pick a hyper can pick a random vertex
from It Whatever the probability of the
vertices we selected that's that's P1
and so to do this in in you pick X and Y
independently okay yeah you're right
thank
you okay and we want balanced also which
just means that we enforce that when we
pick a PA pair of vertices your value is
at least one you're picking balanced the
function is
balanced so I generalized Edge expansion
because D is one as just
remarked and uh we will now reduce from
small set expansion to this problem
which starting to look like vertex
expansion already right and hypergraph
expansion um so actually to okay and
that the reduction in in in in the main
steps follows what was done to prove the
square root of lower bound
inra so for the but let me first show
you the second part which is from here
how do you go toex expans that's the
easy part it's just hting bar so uh what
you do here is you remember this is the
quantity you uh sample a Vertex sample
neighbors and this is basically asking
what is the probability that at least
one y lies outside the
subset because then it's counted in the
numerator otherwise it's not counted and
as we were saying before with d equal to
1 it's the edge expansion and if you
make D is uh D is infinity that means
you're looking at all neighbors you get
vertex expansion Max overall
letters uh now in fact Computing this
quantity is uh implies that you can you
know uh um reduces to Computing the
vertex expansion in graphs with degree
order D why because we have this
distribution we'll just sample a large
enough number of tupes from this fix a
hyper graph and run vertex expansion on
that hyper graph and it will approximate
this this
value okay so we just need to show that
for every function you are truthfully
represented up to a small approximation
so that that's what I meant by hting BS
so now we focus on reducing the hardness
of this problem so this is the reminder
so basically I sketch from here to here
now we need to do this here for the
balance so this is the outline for how
you take an S instance you have a graph
and you want to check is it is there a
subset whose small subset whose
expansion is less than Epsilon or for
every small subset the expansion is
almost one that's the
instance then the point is that you have
this
gadget uh which is a tiny graph in all
previous papers it was a single edge I
think now in our paper it will be three
edges and uh you power it
up this R will be a parameter that
depends on Epsilon so this is a product
graph right so if you take an edge you
get hyper Cube if you take what we have
which is a path of length three we're
going to get some
green and then you take the outer
product with the original instance I
mean the product graph the original
instance and then we have to do some
smoothing it just means that you add
some edges to exclude some some bad
events okay now once you do this claim
is that if the original s instance had
expansion had small set expansion less
than Epsilon then uh your the vertex
expansion of your new big uh uh graph
will be less than Epsilon Prime and if
the small set expansion was large then
in fact the vertic expansion is uh
square is larger but much bigger
Factor okay there is a big gap
here in some Gap
here so the gadget is this this small
graph H is just
this with weights on the vertices you
power it to the
r and
um there's this notion of uh okay so we
have to argue about Cuts right we have
to argue that the if there's a small
if there's a small set with small
expansion it's
preserved that's relatively
easy uh
basically forget about the graph g0 the
instance let's just focus on this
product graph turns out that the
technical um difficulty of proving this
that this reduction has these properties
is to actually prove properties of the
product of this tiny
graph and uh what you want to show is
that if you take a subset of vertices of
the product graph so that you are taking
all copies of some
vertex okay so this is a dictator cut
like if you have a hyper Cube you're
taking uh cutting along a
dimension uh then in fact uh you have
small expansion I mean that's the point
of this right if you cut here here or
here it's it's small and it's this
Remains the case even if you make a
protograph but if you cut in any way
that's sufficiently far and we have to
Define what sufficiently far is then the
expansion is is
huge
and just a combinatorial uh
claim where's
D um D will show up in uh in uh well
well D is already there in the in the uh
so
the in in how we power this up this
power determines the the degree yeah and
and uh
yeah so
it's just an example with h being a
single
edge and basically the difficulty is to
show try to show that for all subsets
which are far from axis cuts the
expansion is large B is now the the
number of times
basically now how do you prove this
comor these comori things even on cubes
are extremely difficult so for this we
have a nice path laid out which is uh to
say that look the quantity you're trying
to estimate is actually very close to
what you would get if you replaced your
distribution on the graph with A
continuous uh gaussian
distribution and then we get a question
about gaussians and maybe that's easier
to
answer um so again this is just a sketch
of what I said you need to show every
subset far from rator has high analytic
expansion for this you show that in fact
you can it's sufficient to prove it for
subsets of a Ian graph which we'll
Define in a minute and uh this is what I
was saying you know uh this is the
function some Boolean inputs which is
whether an edge is present or not and uh
this is where we are adding some noise
meaning some random edges to smooth
out but but the key step here is that
you're replacing Boolean with
gausin so I won't try to summarize
uh um
a lot of work in more than this but okay
so for us this will be the analytic
vertex expansion of the gadget the
powered up Gadget and uh this will be
the analytic vertic expansion of a
gaussian graph so what's this gaussian
graph we're talking about uh it's the
vertex set is all of our end and the
weight on an edge is proportional to the
gausin
density so if you centered at one of the
nodes and you looked at how much G in
weight you get at the other node that
with variance
Epsilon
now um yeah you can also think of it as
um the uh the density that you get u x
is U and Y is V for two correlated
G so
um and then you can ask what is the
analytic expansion of this gausian graph
for any subset if you look at this
function which measure which which which
picks neighbors and so what is what is
what is this question so let me ask make
this question precise we have this G
graph right so it's say RN and your
weights on on all pairs it's complet
weights right and now you ask I take a
subset I pick a vtex at random and I
pick D neighbors according to the edges
and
ask is there at least one outside
my because there's at least one you want
to count so what's the probability that
when I pick a random vertex from the
subset and I pick D Neighbors at least
one Falls outside normally you just ask
if I pick a random vertex and a random
neighbor what's the probity
outside so we're asking this in the
continuous setting and the theorem is
that sorry that in fact uh if uh this
Epsilon correlated you know the Epsilon
is this correlation parameter then you
get square root Epsilon uh log
D Okay so
this uh the proof of this is completely
geometric um know you have a gaussian
and uh you can reduce the question to
the one dimensional
case sorry ignore the comment so I have
some
subset I'm picking a Vertex from it
subset s and I want to know if I pick D
neighbors according to this distribution
what's the probability that one of them
Falls
outside okay so in the proof of square
root opt uh being a lower Bound for
regular Edge expansion it's the same
question with d equal to 1 what is the
isop perimetry of the gaussian graph and
there the answer is square root
Epsilon slightly more complicated
question you're picking D neighbors
what's the probability that one of them
falls
out so um the proof really is one slide
so here is the subset everything on this
side is a subset you are then let me
Define two other subsets one which are
kind of deep inside
okay um how in what sense are the deep
inside this S1 is a subset of all
points okay um so that
um the probability that when I
take a a point here and a neighbor the
probability that it crosses is less than
1 /
2D okay there's some threshold here and
I'm saying what is the I want to fix the
subset so that the probability that it
crosses is less than 1/
2D so uh so of course as I make this
threshold smaller and smaller this will
be a smaller and smaller
subset okay now um by simple gaussian
geometry if you have two vertices whose
distance is small then after if you
apply one if you take one gaussian
neighbor from them then in fact uh if
you apply gaussian centered if you
consider a gaussian centered at those
points and they're close enough the
distributions overlap a
lot okay and
therefore if I now make these sub so
therefore these subsets since they have
very little probability of crossing over
must be far because if they were closer
they would have a probility one over 2D
of crossing over but I I said they don't
they have a very small so they must be
far and in fact the distance is square
root Epsilon
log so that's that's a sorry it's too
rush right now but that's the so in
conclusion uh um distinguishing whether
a graph is uh has a Vertex expansion
less than Epson 0 or at least .1 is uh
is the problem and uh as far as we can
tell this is hard if you believe the
SS and so this is a summary of the sort
of the algorithmic approximation bounds
on this problem so you know there's a ra
square root log n for the two problems
and then Square this came earlier but
since it's different in put it here and
then uh this is what the simple s DP
gives us um it's also known this is the
strongest result we know assuming the
exponential time hypothesis there is no
PS for these
problems uh and this is what uh RS
proved that square root opt holds for
Edge expansion which implies also for
verx expansion and this is what we just
SOL square root opt log D is a here are
some questions of course better
approximation right uh
sense I I I I love this algorithm so
maybe you've seen it uh I first heard it
from Gary Miller he says the following
you know um Cher says take the lassan
take the second Dion Vector sort it and
take consider the N minus one Cuts take
the best car says take all the N minus
one
vectors sort all of them sort a sort the
ver all of them consider all the N minus
one cuts from each of them so you get
about n squ Cuts take the best of
those okay
uh the worst known example for this is
uh square root
login but we don't know how to prove
better than Square
opt so I guess show show that this
problem is actually NP hard the
expansion problem not SS the 2
1.0 finally this process that we I
mentioned one difference from a random
walk is that we don't know how to do
this implemented locally so for a random
walk you just to know the current vertex
and you keep moving that's all you need
to remember the the identity of the
current vertex this one as far as you
can tell you have to keep track of the
entire distribution to update
it so is there some local implementation
of this then the process could have
applications to other
things
that's
questions
uh so for the dispersion process I guess
one thing that makes it hard is the the
max but are there variance of it that uh
that don't use it that that could give
similar results like know so so you know
instead of the the two Norm you could
try a different Norm for example in
instead of summing up the squares you
could sum up the square root of the
fourth powers and so on all seem to give
weaker results without having a
natural uh the sum of squares great
polinomial time random work everything
is great any other Norm I don't see an
advantage this one gives the best bound
we off so no I don't know yeah so if you
find a fixed point of your uh diffusion
process so then that really quotient
like expression will give you gamma 2
then gamma 2 gives you root of the
approximation for the hyper graph
expansion and so
then that gives you a solution to small
set expansion yes so that must mean that
Computing GMA to that finding that fix
point should
Beast to bre under s yes yeah this is
what I was saying that it's going to be
hard in this sense but I don't know if
yeah that's right
yeah yeah so since s you said it's kind
of ridiculous
anyway know I was trying to more
ridiculous than you NE con yeah yeah I I
said ridiculous only to wake up people
obviously it's interesting because it's
leading to lots of questions but like do
you have a sense that in fact there are
cases where the convergence time is
exponential for your diffusion
process I mean um is also here I don't
know if prad is here but uh do we have
exponential time lower bounds for the
thing is that you can always find a
fixed point is that you will not be able
to certify that it is the one
corresponding to the smallest one so if
you he's asking can it be exponentially
small the gamma 2 yeah uh I mean in the
same reason right for as the spectral
gap of a graph can be expon
uh you have a weighted oh depending on
the weights but let's say it's
unweighted let's say it's a weights of
course but if it's uned then equality
shows that it is lower bounded by one
over poly yes oh yeah one over
poly there is many maybe there's
exponential number of fix points and
you'll find the bad one that's the kind
of no every fix point will give you GMA
to I mean there's a unique fix Point
that's right that's right under this
very mild exactly yes that's the point
so we keep discussing yeah just maybe
time we can probably continue this
conversation over dinner
yeah good so let's
thank